you
all right we are in an hourly bullet
arena at the moment 17 are in here 18
but I imagine there will be a spillover
from the previous tournament oh my god
that's not a good start 3 Mouse slippers
right in the beginning that's a bit
surprising y-squared Bishop's on or off
okay what's the plan okay pick up that
pawn and just just consolidate I want a
flight square that's all
flight squares in this is my only base
point
to an open file
Oh in exchange
another pond okay now we just improve
the king I had that
you
got the rooks off
plenty of time in this one no sneaky
stalemates I'll let that pawn live for a
bit
the rosy stuff
oh my god that guy can't do this to a
higher gear I did not need three Queens
I did not want to get three Queens that
just increases the probability of
getting stalemates one queen I just want
him to get out of the way move you know
the way pounds somebody's trying to
avoid stalemate okay where does this guy
want to be coordinated on h2o
this is a problem this is gonna be
making 1 2 3 4 discovered check check in
the h2 square all right quick win still
a lot of time and journey to nm Deni 165
oh we have played not much but we have
played all right let's try to challenge
a piece that's in my house immediately
those are gonna cost me I get the b2
pond and I could work on these light
square weaknesses all right I'll just
save them light squares light squares
let's let's be a surgeon
killer bees mmm check okay we are we're
winning we're winning stuff
it's insert this check oh okay I'll take
now check another check we could win
pawns with check a lot of pawns let's
take another
queen is hungry
okay they resigned I didn't know what
they were playing so fast what's with
that f6 move if f6 is played and you
can't get in a 5 it's Jens up being a
big weakness that's how I see it at
least all right no no no bishop before
huh
tonight's gonna camp out here yepper
um let's see if my night is captured all
right I try this it's interesting yeah I
have this to defend night they're still
go here unprovoked
I need a square for the night it's a big
night my king wants to move towards the
Queen side let's do it right now
anything bad gonna happen I'll go over
with this rook in case c5 is challenged
I have that okay
create some weaknesses don't want to
give this pawn some ability what would I
like to have happen here Queen right
here in the center get out of the way
King go one step I don't want the Queen
side to open up too easily what are you
up to Queen no good right in the center
okay now we do this lock it down
I'm preparing an exchange sacrifice oh I
could to just capture the Queen yeah
that was possible um I got that pawn
it's being sneaky it's being sneaky yes
he's really fast my time Oh God
me
oh my god I barely pulled that move off
what is going on I'm thinking too much
would you just move hmm okay we're live
that's all I have time for just a a
quick glance to see if we're still live
we're live we have a mover Knight f6 now
let's see if oh really
really all right what's what's happening
here careful now careful dangerous Forks
are nearby why am i giving up that pawn
let's create some and buy I could have
captured here holy cow
okay we could try it again not the
not the best way to do it Queen here
looking for caveman whoa oh oh god I
could defend that I have Knight f6 I
almost believed my opponent never
believed your opponent let's get rid of
this Knight no mate threats if the
knight is cooked Forks picking up
another piece light squares where's that
nikon get the Queen out of here whoa
didn't see that move
night here should be dangerous check
this night is an absolute monster this
queen should be trapped somehow Wow
there's no oh my God my time my opponent
has one piece discovered check King back
it's me all right they're playing so
fast they had one piece but it was
somehow going into pac-man all right I
love I love the exchange Caro simple to
play especially for bullet keep the
bishop around give me a flight square
maybe we jump in here hmm all right
see how annoying
night can be on c3 now this might be a
move might okay who the bishop is a
goner you got a little fancy I could
have just captured their take here then
here on the night
maybe insert a check for
then when I take the night there's a pin
on this now now they have to block with
the something and in the end I am up a
rook flight square right around the
corner they resigned okay so who sixteen
minutes to go
a seventy are in here let's see who we
get next Somebody Anybody 2013 12 12s a
lot of 12s it's try knee for game
caro-kann on the other side main line
okay play this in the Simon
let's okay let's go here 9c five
something could I could drop the let's
just centralize I could drop the bishop
back to c1
dropping up on okay now I know I just
want to take and go here defend this
pawn and threaten this
this Queen doesn't like having that
responsibility um how do I want to do it
I want to keep one rook on can't really
share why that's the case
oh my god I didn't realize that was
possible yikes it's in sir - check
careful King fancy fancy taking the rook
and then we're taking the Queen
something better just want to get this
pawn next I'm down on the clock
you
Wow why am I giving up that pond so
easily let's get another passer ten
seconds
seconds okay I should be able to pull
this one off hmm I don't know I can't
I'd I can't play fast as fast as I want
I don't know I want to play faster and
I'm down in time in so many of the games
it's tough alright got twenty four
sixteen sixteen thirteen still two
players or also don't have a loss
Chinchin let's try French when war on
the right exchange council here let's
play play within a simple structure on
the on this side I'm considering taking
that yeah let's try it now yeah somebody
missed miss mouse clicks let's try this
and then here
Queen there could be strong I think my
night has finally found a good square
yeah if only I had Queen d6 a little
earlier want some trades get on an open
file thing I want to keep the
Queens on its that about huh my pawn
lives
let's take here I don't want the Queen I
don't want this pawn as some shelter
give me shelter let's run a little bit
there's checks
I can block I'm on the bishop - on the
bishop right now just do something
active Queens gonna give a check ooh
night somewhere over here I could hunt
that pawn king is still on a dark square
the bishop can't move this is a King and
pawn endgame
now can move okay okay
simple to play out or pre move out there
down on time I didn't know what I was
saying just then they were there's a
King and pawn endgame as long as I kept
my knight on that one square all right
grünfeld now Kings Indian defense let's
just grab some space h6 g5 let's do this
right now
and let's start prepare I'm giving my
opponent and opportunity for oh my
bishops dead I was supposed to have
seeth f3 and yes alright we could still
we could still hope for something closed
a little bit
this Bishop is dead cancel out the night
yeah I have space I want to jump right
in and have this square that nights
going to struggle yeah their pieces are
struggling a little bit and their King
might be a rip to shreds actually no I
don't know if this is the greatest
square for my queen mmm
I'm going to do something a little crazy
town I'm gonna allow that rook to be
active
go here and just break open I want to I
want to get at the King I need to get at
the king um okay I'm getting the night
I'm getting more than that I could take
the night with Chuck and I should be
getting the Queen now
Chuck just advanced I have that
we're covered no stalemates no
stalemates who dodged a bullet there
fortunately though those space invader
ponds really influence the quality of my
opponents pieces
so let's see if they bite yes okay
and yes we scooped it up like this no no
no no to prepare for this file to open
up castles take like that get here
very fast Bishop's defended by my night
knight on d4
knight on c6
I could do this in the end I'm on the
night this tactic here and then here I
don't think is working I haven't picking
up the exchange check just get on the
open file let's give a check defend that
pawn
why am i running into that let's regroup
I want to kick the night away
I have to defended it's really trying to
get here g5 no g5
there
time hmm only six minutes remaining this
one is flying by okay let's see we get
next Somebody Anybody
all right
[Music]
BOGO it is
we're playing within this cozy structure
I want to stop III beef a quick a 3 B 4
I should just captured
and stop this
step my king up
my hmm let's try and okay now we're
gonna work on this square I'm gonna
eliminate this night and try to
eliminate the bishop now this is really
good for me just kick the night away
doesn't want to go
it's opening up like this I want to
square for my my king
important defender tough to assess this
one I got to make a faster move
okay
having a closed I'll give this square up
clean right here
be doing though dropping this pawn
rook takes pawn
no time burner City like I was so locked
up oh I shouldn't have given up the e5
square that was stupid
we're just gonna try and build in the
center that's all baby step it well
let's see if we could show that my light
square bishop is pesky ooh Knight has to
go here my in trouble if I go over there
may be a bishop returning it's played as
a gambit I want this square for my
knight um all right I guess we take no
gain a tempo against the Queen one day
late here
careful now I don't have a light square
bishop and argue I do I get that right
ooh they resigned hitting the rook and
made on h72 35 remaining
44 28 24 24 22 97 sky again okay we're
probably gonna have this same structure
again likes this capture Oh something
wrong 5150 connection issue it's not on
my and I don't think oh they have a
connection issue
that's a problem hmm yeah what can you
do yeah
they're not here they left the game they
must have got hit with a Comcast game
but I know I know the feeling oh they're
back that was a quick reconnection
my LightSquared bishop needs to play I'm
dropping upon
clean clothes to trap now I'm half
playing for time
tal picked our bishop
I wanted to open up
some
the bishop now
yeah that really hurt them clearly the
connection that's going to do it that's
the final tournament pairings closed
48:28 2824 let's see how it finishes up
any last minute winds possibly journey
to nm looks to be yeah we'll have second
as the fire we didn't get paired up 13
games in okay let's see all the pages
two three
dr. cliffhanger I see turnaround is in
there oxy caveman who else professor
sunset kid and turkey chili
well these players didn't didn't even
get a game in okay that's the full list
to the 97 of you good games all alright
you